[Music]
foreign
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with
Guardian columnist Zoe Williams and
Deputy political editor at this
spectator Katie balls so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now D-Day 4pm will more u-turns save
our economy ask the front of the Daily
Express as Liz truss's economic policies
continue to be scrutinized
the front of the Daily Mirror reflects
the same story as they look at the Tory
MPS who've publicly told the prime
minister to quit
The Daily Telegraph also looks at the
same story this time quoting penny
mordant in their headline we need
stability not a soap opera
the front of the Daily Mail reads plot
to topple truss this week
Tories hold secret talks on crowning new
leader reads the times as they too look
at potential Rebels within the Tory
party
and the front of the Guardian also runs
with this story their headline trust
fights for survival as Tory Rebel MPS
warn that the game is up
Tories in truss turmoil the plot thicken
is the front of the Metro
and the eye also leads with this story
their headline trust faces challenge
within days
and in other news the front of the Daily
Star looks at plans to sell the late
Queens horses
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Zoe
Williams and Katie Bulls welcome to you
both let us start with the mirror um
only really one story on the front page
but I'm wondering whether you believe
the Prime Minister will take the advice
of certain Tory MPS which is to quit Now
Zoe
I mean she's not going to quit Okay you
you if she were going to quit she would
have quit already so it will have to be
regicide but you know commentators have
already said it's not going to be a
regicide it's going to be euthanasia
she's dying on her feet she can't
actually get anything through this
Parliament so the notion of her being on
charge is it in charge is not just
destabilizing for the country it's very
destabilizing for the markets it's very
stabilizing for everybody she's like
manifestly not in charge of the party
um
I think and I really hate saying this
because
you know it's very very problematic to
say I speak on behalf of the nation but
I think the country has had enough of
the conservative party deciding what's
right and what's wrong I mean it's
absolutely had enough they put these
clowns in charge and we have this
turmoil and then they put another clown
in charge so my sense is that if they
don't have a general election soon after
they depose list Liz trust they're going
to be in really serious trouble
what's your view Katie do you agree with
Zoe that the prime minister is unlikely
to to resign
yes I mean everything suggests that the
prime minister is digging in I think Liz
trust has shown throughout her career
too that she is someone who
often you know in a way she is a fighter
and I think in this case lots of Korean
piece probably wish she was not
um but I don't think dining street is
going to walk away from this one without
trying and therefore in for I think a
pretty unpredictable few days and weeks
in terms of how this plays all out and
as Zoe says you have a situation where
although I think now lots of MPS agree
that they no longer want Liz trust to be
their leader there's no consensus on who
actually they should replace Liz trust
with and therefore you don't actually
have a plan and you have a situation
where you could actually create a
already very messy situation make it
even more chaotic and then the cause for
a general election are only going to
grow further so of course MPS do need to
vote for one and at the moment I I think
most Tory MPS would look at the polls
and think that that's the last thing
they want to do so we read in the Daily
Mail that mutinous backbench MPS are
pressing Tory shop stewards for Graham
Brady to tell the Prime Minister her
time is up or change party rules to
allow an immediate vote of confidence in
her leadership and we also read that
former Minister Kristen blunt has said
the game is up it's now a question as to
how to to manage the succession
I mean look it's it's extraordinary
right in in the Tories Ideal World
nobody would know the name Graham Brady
they just wouldn't know who he was and
it wouldn't matter whether or not he was
on holiday in Greece this is a Tory
nightmare that everything is hanging on
the chair of the 1922 committee because
what it means is that everybody's
waiting to see whether he will do
something extraordinary change the rules
so that her leadership can be challenged
within the first 12 months of her
taking power or whether he'll just sit
on his hands it it's really much more
problematic than I think even the Tory
MPS who are leaking like a ship leaking
like a leaky thing are admitting it's it
it's really extraordinary that we're
that we even can see so much into the
way they operate is extraordinary now
the problem is the problem with leaving
it for the Tory party is that none of
the factions agree so you've got the
modern that you've got the modern
Challenge and the fact that she's being
so open is quite Salient I think here
then you've got the Ben Wallace safe
Pair of Hands challenge then you've got
the kind of randoms the kind of randoms
from the right then you've got the
people the kind of commentariat saying
wouldn't it be great if Jeremy Hunt was
in charge because he seems so calm and
reasonable and empathetic now if they
could coalesce behind one of those
options they might have a chance of
keeping this kind of limping government
on but they can't coalesce so what
you're seeing is actually like brexit
all over again none of them can agree so
it's going to end up in chaos yeah and
we have a look at the telegraph next and
Penny Morton who's written about this is
saying that what they need now is
stability and not a soap opera she still
seemingly uh supporting of the Prime
Minister but as we know she was a a
rival and it seems as if that she might
be keeping that Avenue open Katie
yes Penny Morgan is being talked up as
part of this and I'm using quote marks
here dream ticket
um going around Tory MPS of Rishi sunic
and Penny Morden
and so I think it's interesting that um
in her rosity of the house she's written
this op-ed in support of this trust it's
also quite interesting because if we
just go back a week or two to Tory Party
Conference Penny Morton was one of the
members
um of the those attending cabinet who
was actually speaking out quite
liberally going further number attempt
have liked so for example Penny Morgan
gave an interview but she said she
thought benefits should in rise in line
of inflation which went furling
government policy at the time and that
caused I think issues uh you know with
up above and therefore there is clearly
an effort to say let's all be loyal um
even if the past few weeks has been
quite loose
um I think it's an interesting one in
terms of where this all goes and how
this week plays out there's lots of MPS
here saying there will be a challenge
this week and if it's not this week
it'll be next week we cannot keep going
as things are but then you also have MPS
you know Matt Hancock Rob halff and
others today going out in the media and
saying they're very unhappy but they're
not at the point point where they're
going to call for Liz trust to go yet
and as ever of these things it's all
about timing which might also explain
why some members of cabinet want to seem
loyal at least for the time being
interesting uh the Metro they tell us
that uh the plots are plural thicken
plot one uh Rebels wants to enact more
than ticket plot two
um others want Ben Wallace and plot
three the chancellor is tipped for the
the top job
um many saying actually now that the
prime minister is in office but not
effectively in power Zoe
you know Katie very elegantly made that
you know there are a number of people
who are who are really saying very
critical things but they're not ready to
make the final leap but I actually see
it a different way you know Robert
Hoffman is openly saying he's he's
making the most extraordinary analogies
between Liz truss and her policies and
you know jihadist terrorism
um fundamentalism of the most extreme
kind so even if he's not saying directly
I think she should know
he's sort of saying she should go what
whichever way you cut it
um I think what will happen in the
splice is that Jeremy Hunt will get the
support of the kind of mainstream press
and probably that will sweep in the kind
of Daily Mail
um express view of things I think the
modern soon actica is the One Tori
insiders one and I think Ben Wallace is
the one that they kind of lean towards
when they're trying to still look like
they've got control of control of events
um in in to my mind it doesn't actually
matter which of those tickets they go on
because the policies will be the same
either way
um their problem will remain they don't
have a mandate and the Very fact that
they've got these kind of competing
candidates for a safe Pair of Hands just
illustrates how little of a mandate they
have or they've got a mandate for is
somebody preventing chaos they don't
have a mandate for anybody doing policy
or government
Zoe and Katie for the moment uh thank
you and the day Express are detailing
that uh trophonomics is a well and truly
uh dead we're going to be talking a
little bit more about that after the
break but coming up more including this
story on the front of the Daily Mail
headline hundreds of disgraceful met
officers should be booted out stay with
us for more on that story and others
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Guardian called
misso Williams and Deputy political
editor at The Spectator Katie balls let
us have a look at the daily mail at
front page and moving away from politics
for the moment this story about uh
disgraced or actually the headline is
disgraceful met officers and the fact
that they should be uh booted out of the
force because of being accused of crimes
including sexual assault domestic abuse
corruption and fraud this is all coming
out in a a review published tomorrow Zoe
it's really funny with the map right
because we have this this is a really
live issue with Guardian readers because
we have this column called dining across
the divide and one of the questions is
are the Met institutionally sexist so
there's a it's a really live discussion
and you hear a lot of different views
and at root it comes down to will this
work itself out over time or does terms
need to come from the top
um and I think it's pretty self-evident
that it won't work itself out over time
you know Society has really moved on
some of the stuff that's come out about
the things going on in the Met WhatsApp
groups are so far behind where we are
what we consider to be acceptable
is really obvious they're not moving on
and whether that's because the kind of
institutional culture is rotten whether
that's because people are attracted to
authoritarian roles who refuse to
confirm conform to you know societal
Norms whatever the reason is there needs
to be some kind of root and Branch
change
um and I you know it's it's a really
easy go-to in a way to say Dwayne
cousins Affair the Wayne cousins crime
and murder suggests that they need to
change I don't that's not where I where
I would where I would start I would say
that was an apparent appalling crime but
you know this overall culture whether it
results in crime or not needs to be
tackled from the top
um Katie are you um convinced that there
will be change we have the Commissioners
Mark Rowley saying that the office is
involved uh undermining Integrity of the
force and should be sacked does that
signal to you that that changes effort
I mean it's almost stating the obvious
to say that it's undermining
the profession
um and also to say that these people
should be sect I mean obviously this is
the person in charge they haven't been
in that position for so long and so you
would expect some consequences to come
from this I think as Zuri touches on
um not just the case she mentioned but
just generally speaking
um from recent uh reports on various uh
ways police treated women in the media
the figures sad they don't become as
particularly surprising that there seems
to be an Institutional widespread
problem and but I think there's one
thing saying there's a problem is
obviously quite a different one having
any evidence to point to that you're
really taking the stance of pushing
these people out to the profession sorry
let's have a look at the times and uh
potentially a very good news story
vaccines to fight cancer could be widely
available before 2030.
I mean it's
look there is an element that we're also
desperate for some good news that
anything would look like good news but
yeah of course this is extraordinary
news and the the cancer oncologists
always said that when we disaggregated
one cancer from another then we'd start
to understand it properly and that does
seem to be what's happened here that you
know we've started to understand that
it's not one disease and that has
contributed to the development of
a kind of
broad spectrum vaccine
um plus the fact of course that you know
the speed of the covid vaccine I think
has really put some Firepower under the
what's possible and how fast it can
happen
so and Casey we have a run out of time
uh thank you both for taking us through
the newspapers we'll see you in the next
hour thank you